I want to thank you for something else  about I don't know like just gonna be  like seven weeks eight weeks ago now I  saw something for the MTV Movie Awards  and you were kind enough to shoot a  quick thing with me where we are in bed  together and you agreed you just said  yeah come and use my real house yeah so  I had the weird experience of lying in  your bed with you in your house right  like early on a Sunday morning it was  there we are  that's my bad is your real bed yeah and  you were spooning me the weird part from  me I have to admit was we get there and  it's what always happens we get there  we're ready to go we're underneath the  covers together in your bed and then  they have to start adjusting a camera  there's something wrong like we'll be a  minute so you and I are just lying in  bed and it sort of started to feel  normal  [Laughter]  there's Elijah Wood yeah I mean his bed  you